for the past three weeks consumers have
had access to over-the-counter hearing
aids well what makes someone a good
candidate for this an expert weighs in
with what you should know and do before
making this type of purchase
[Music]
with the fda's approval over-the-counter
hearing aids now available at CVS
Walgreens retailers like Walmart and
Best Buy without requiring a medical
exam certified EMT surgeon Dr sarik
turakuri says having this option is a
long overdue change that can be a good
thing for certain people it is designed
for people with mild to moderate hearing
loss
vast majority of people we see in our
ear nose and throat clinics are moderate
to severe or Worse people with moderate
to severe hearing loss often require
custom-made hearing aids that can run
twenty three hundred dollars a unit
over-the-counter hearing aids can cost
between 200 and 1200 a pair a great
option for some considering 80 percent
of people who would benefit from a
hearing aid don't wear anything at all
one could be cost and lack of insurance
coverage Medicare still does not cover
prescription hearing aids another thing
is Vanity stigma denial when it comes to
selection it can be tough the doctor
went to several stores and wasn't
impressed saying many were out of stock
and sales people had no clue I do hope
the retail outlets become a little more
educated over time and could counsel the
people that come in meantime Dr chura
Curry suggests the following for anyone
suffering with hearing loss go see a
doctor of some sort have somebody look
in your ear and get a hearing test those
are covered by Insurance a lot of places
give hearing tests for free and that way
you at least know where you stand and if
you're in that mild to moderate category